(laughter)
- Oh, scratching the butt.
(playful piano music)
- Hey, I'm Jordan, and my sister Aviva
is visiting from out of town.
There is nobody on the planet
who loves monkeys more than my sister.
My sister even talked about a
monkey in her wedding speech.
- Your unconditional
support is like no other.
I mean, you even let me think
I could be a monkey mother.
(laughter)
- At her preschool graduation
she said that what she wants
to be when she grows
up is a mother monkey.
And when she found out
she couldn't be one she cried for days.
I officiated my sister's
wedding and I really wanted
to surprise her with a
monkey as the ring bearer
but we weren't able to work it out there,
so now I'm gonna surprise
her with a monkey today.
It's gonna destroy her.
- [Male Voice] What are
you here to do today?
- Jordan and I are going to
transform into each other through make-up.
He's my little brother,
so it'll be interesting.
The only thing that we
really look alike in
is that we both have brown eyes.
I think it's gonna be funny and I think
it's gonna be awkward for sure.
But if she nails it, then I'm gonna be
in awe of the make-up artist.
(gasping)
Oh my goodness.
- [Male Voice] This is Dexter.
- Hi Dexter.
Oh my God!
I love monkeys, I'm so excited!
Oh my goodness!
Hi, hi!
Oh, hello!
This is so awesome, I'm so excited.
I'm sorry, I'm freaking out.
I love monkeys and I never
get to be around them.
When my husband and I got married
we had two little monkeys
on top of our cake.
It's always been that I've wanted to do
is spend time with them.
Jordan had me convinced I was
here for some other reason.
(laughter)
- There he goes.
Hey there.
- Look, you're a natural!
- He sneezed on me!
(laughter)
- Well, I was super surprised.
I didn't think Jordan could
surprise me, but he did.
In fact, I'm just so excited
to be around a monkey.
So this experience has
been amazing for me.
I can't say enough.
I can't stop looking at this monkey.
[Unison] Hi.
(laughter)
- This expression when
he did that is amazing.
- He's awesome, he's full of energy
and he's awesome.
I'm jealous that I don't get to keep him.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.